choosing a supplement company who adhere
the best practice could be the single
best decision that an athlete makes
across the whole lifetime here in Nelson
we manufacture over 300 products use or
which have manufactured on site it's
important that integrity and Trust is a
cornerstone of everything that we do
have you scientist bought products for
the last 20 years and there's one simple
reason behind that because I trust them
I know the lengths they go to the test
revanche substances the world leaders in
that and as an athlete when you're
putting your reputation on the line you
have to know that any product you're
using are 100% safe
[Music]
I'm responded Fi it's really well over
the last season and you know I think one
thing that I really enjoy about SAS is
the trust that I have in the product not
only the level of scrutiny that products
go through to make sure that they're not
contaminated but also just how the
products are tested and how we can use
them as a team and we know that we're
getting consistent reliable product
every time effective there's three key
steps that you take to ensure the
integrity of our products and we can
really build upon the trust and the
authentication firstly we raw materials
we risk assess any potential risks of
contamination
second we undertake random swab testing
of production equipment and finally we
ensure that the enormity of the
manufacture have also checked for our
substance setting both at the start the
middle and the end of each production
cycle and through those processes were
able to ensure that we don't have any
risk of contamination of our finished
goods out in the marketplace the
informed support testing is is huge not
only just for me myself as a
practitioner in terms of knowing that I
can give the athletes to supplement
that's going to be fully tested and not
going have any kind of banned substances
in it but so then was as athletes
themselves you know they see that logo
on on things and they instantly know
that it's going to be safe for them to
take as is is approached advanced custom
sensing is super important obviously you
see these stories where people test
positive do to attain to supplement and
there's basically no way around it
there's nowhere to trust someone after
that
it more or less can ruin a career and
for us these kids they're 19 20 years
old they're preparing themselves for
something that's hopefully going to
change their life so for all the hard
work they put in to risk that getting
thrown away because of a change of
supplement or something like that is
completely unacceptable so for us having
something that we believe in and can
trust giving to the riders is critical
you have to have that high level of
confidence in anything that the athletes
will be putting their number house and
put into the body and we need to make
sure that every precaution is taken
seriously and the standards are upheld
and of course that's what's SS attitude